kids
of yes you have grandkids i do okay so
uh are you
uh concerned or suspicious that a
potential super emp could one day be
you know
used by an enemy of ours against us in
america
that was the option next option i'm
thinking the putin is getting advice on
from
some factions because among his cyber
warriors there are others who are going
to say we should go bigger than just
attacking european nato but a basic
fundamental question do you think
are you suspicious that one day that an
attack like that with a super emp could
be used against american that would
impact negatively your your kids your
grandkids under these circumstances in
this ukrainian war i'm i'm very fearful
that it could happen tomorrow okay so
how are you personally prepared for it
you know well we have a a little farm
that's uh all set up you know we're
prepared to live without electricity uh
you know and you own a little farm that
you're you're ready for it yes okay got
it and what kind of food do you have
that in case that were to happen
you know you're ready how many months of
supply of food you have because some
people may be listening to this they're
also sitting there saying you know some
who maybe have the ability to do so you
don't buy life insurance policy because
you're thinking you're going to die
tomorrow you you buy because if you do
you want your wife your husband your
okay so so
what kind of food do you have how much
supply of food you have how prepared are
you very prepared you know while we've
got the ability to
to survive for years
for years yes uh you know the location
of my farm is uh
well i'm not going to talk about where
it's located okay but it's just a very
remote uh remote place it's close enough
to washington so that i can go there
when i have to uh you know but it's far
enough away it's one of the least
populous counties in virginia so that if
we were to exhaust our canned food and
we've got plenty of that that's what i
would recommend you know stockpiling
high caloric canned food you know beans
chocolate peanuts you know
spaghetti
all kinds of canned food because that
way rodents can't get at it and canned
food will basically last forever i mean
even though they have expiration dates
on the canned food you know that's just
for quality of appearances in terms of
the wholesomeness of the food
because it's in a vacuum it'll basically
last forever we we recovered
there was an arctic expedition
that was lost
in the early 1800s
and nobody knew what had happened to
them
you know for uh you know for many years
uh but we eventually found them uh you
know more than a century after the
expedition had failed they were one of
the first expeditions that were bringing
canned food with with them and the and
the food was still good you know uh
years after uh years after that water is
critical you know
uh you know uh
uh it's best to actually have a natural
well you know so that you're not
dependent upon
uh you know
the larger water infrastructure
uh
uh you you can make homemade filters
quite easily with a garbage can and
blankets and charcoal that would uh that
would uh that would uh uh
refine water purify pure purify water
but uh uh it's a good excuse for having
a swimming pool you know twenty thousand
gallon swimming pool you know it can be
one of those above ground pools that are
very inexpensive i mean this is not the
kind of thing you need to be a
millionaire to be able to afford
everybody should be able to you know be
survivable that'll not only could you
support your family with that but you
could probably provide have a water
supply that would support a whole
community do all the members of your
family have something like this yes
and this is something that you
encouraged them to do or they've read
enough of your books and material that
they said all right i'm convinced i got
to move on with this
well both either way that's uh yeah
that's uh you know both because they've
read my stuff and been around been
around me so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]
you